so everybody knows at this point we
hired this new you know friend of ours
vincent o'shannon who's an actor and a
comedian was part of deaf comedy jam i
think kevin hart interviewed him they
did a lot of different work so when when
he came on board to the valuetainment
team i said look one of the things we
can do is i'd like to see you go around
the world go around different places and
you know where we can find out where's
vinnie and he's going so apparently can
we go to vinnie real quick yeah hey i
think vinnie's live right now hey vinnie
is it true that what mario just text me
what room you're in
get the hell out of here hold on what in
nancy pelosi's office i can't see the
picture can you get a little closer
you're in nancy pelosi's office
we came to washington to make videos for
valuetainment we did a tour of the
capitol and her door was open
bro your mom's gonna kill me if she says
you hire my son and he goes to jail what
is this guy doing
my mom takes her too but look pat look
at
look how loose
and then look at that
this guy's looking through her office
look at this did you just pull that out
of her desk vinnie wow
that's not me what is he doing dr moore
here
what is this 100 percent that's not hd
vinnie it's out can you hear me vinnie
listen
number one i think you should get the
hell out of there but while you're there
see what's in the desk would you
yeah okay i think he drank the other
half of that bottle adam look look oh my
god
those are safety oh my god
after the dui respect
she's creative
very progressive okay what else do you
guys think what else you got vinnie
honestly just the last thing in and get
out
what do the last thing and then get out
don't stay there too long okay all right
well pat look at this insider training
for dummy yeah no [ __ ]
oh
and then look
the art of the deal
is he making this out well look that
nancy despite what we show the public i
can't wait for us to make america great
again it's going to be huge your dear
friend
trump vinnie
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god it's [ __ ] it's definitely
cocaine
okay
go go
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]